so Linda's let's say you're at a place
where you're not about competition as
much you've let some of that go but
you're sensing from someone else that
they more about that what's an approach
is to affirm them because many times
people feel competitive because of the
negatives and when you put the positive
in and to save for instance you are so
good at style or you are so funny or you
are I mean Alma anything that says I'm
not going to get hooked up by your
insecurities and I want to give above
that we have a saying in my office that
we treat everyone as human beings even
if they don't act to act like one with
once in a while people don't act like
human beings say nevertheless you treat
them as a human being with respect and
you build them up and you nurture them
and you you help make them feel good
about themselves because that
competition comes from insecurity and
and I mean we all go there we all go
those places the big thing is is to
fight it and to just say I don't want to
live here I don't in I've been very
interested in the subject i wrote a book
on this subject called the better way to
win connecting that competing for
success because i saw so much and i
worked so hard to overcome this inside
myself and I began to study this whole
idea of competitive thinking so that i'm
going to write a book on it so it's one
of mine on screen writing books a lesson
about yourself that you're almost
embarrassed to admit that you so long to
realize well i think we just talked
about that it was getting over my
competitive feelings and they were
really knowing at me and i worked really
really hard at that in the 1980s when i
saw was when those feelings are coming
up and i just resisted them i prayed
about them i'm a spiritual person and i
just found you know I just said I don't
want to live
here and and I would say that was
probably my biggest lesson in the
business say I don't want to go there
and they do pop up once in a while and
just say don't want to go there no we're
not going to go there well you're not
going to do this I think two were in an
age of social media where now people can
be competitive behind their screen and
CEO what's so until working on and
there's a there's a temptation to
indulge ourselves how do we stop that
Aang say you know what I'm just going to
focus on my life yeah whatever they're
doing is great for them yes yeah and I
mean I think that's just what you do is
you sit down and you breathe deeply
that's a lot of breathing deeply that's
very important and just say what am I
about and there is a thing it's so easy
to fall into that too to get off track
and one of the things I often say to
myself and am I telling the truth am I
saying true to my calling is that if I
stay true you know whether we call it
our where we're being led or called or
however we want to say that our mission
and life are objective our goal whatever
if we stand that track I think that's
where we stay safe in it so it becomes
very important not to let somebody else
push us off that and and sometimes that
means it takes the data answer an email
that's trying to do it or to just sit
down now I got my favorite rocking chair
or sitting room and I just sit down say
okay take a deep breath i'm not going to
go there that is not that is not where
the good or that's not where the value
lies and it's not where I want to live
but it is work you know it is is work to
keep thing else we're not going to be
there
you